dans sa communauté ou devant les
tribunaux jackie vautour était le
symbole d'une résistance acadienne le
leader de 200 familles expropriées à la
fin des années 60 par les gouvernements
pour la création du parc national
kouchibouguac sur la côte est du nouveau
brunswick
si par exemple que les gros bourgeois
acadien aurait voulu on n'aurait pas
parlé du les terres étions alors les
1200 cadiens expropriés étaient parmi
les plus pauvres de la province
à l'époque ils n'ont reçu qu'un maigre
dédommagement pour quitter leurs
villages et leurs maisons d'une longe la
dèche sur l'autre nouvelle gmail gmail
après des émeutes dans le parc national
une commission d'enquêté créée elle
donnera en partie raison aux expropriés
et le reçoivent un million six cent
mille dollars
jackie vautour sa femme yvonne et leurs
neuf enfants sont malgré tout restés
dans le parc
d'abord dans un camp de fortune puis
dans une roulotte sans électricité ou le
couple habitait toujours avant
l'hospitalisation du nonagénaire
atteints de cancers du foie et souffrant
d'une pneumonie
j'ai descendu à son fils edmond reprend
le flambeau de newt dont les blessures
sont toujours profonde et qui rappellent
à certains la déportation acadienne sera
plus là en même temps pour lui et
plusieurs autres
dès qu'ils vautours était un héros
revenir et au mentorat cadiens il est
probablement celui qui peut signifier le
mieux
la régie viaur acadienne et métis il
incarne et des enjeux actuels notamment
le taux n'est ni alimentaire jackie
vautour voulait chasser et pêcher sur
ses terres en vertu de son statut 2006
acadien extrêmement humble c'est
quelqu'un qui est qu'il offre aux prises
la quasi par un grain un grand résistant
un grand homme un grand qui a lutté
contre des injustices un symbole même
avant son dernier souffle
ces mots ont été pour les expropriés
dont certains étaient réunis devant
l'hôpital depuis 2000
parcs canada exproprie plus de canadiens
pour l'expansion de son réseau et ses
mots montambault radio-canada moncton